Mohammed names mother rots orange mint
on his bruises the 35 year old says he
was attacked by a group of men when he
was out selling vegetables on his cart
after asking my name they said you're a
Muslim you've destroyed the country
you've spread Karuna virus and then
started beating me with sticks there
were five or six of them community
leaders in the doddery neighborhood of
author Pradesh state told Al Jazeera the
Muslims have been harassed and attacked
since a gathering of Islamic preachers
in Delhi led to a riots in the number of
coronavirus cases has ISA Laden's car
window was broken in the middle of the
night he says he'd been receiving phone
calls from relatives telling him about
rumors that his son attended the event
and Delhi rumors are being spread around
that the corona virus is being spread by
the Jamaat police are investigating the
incidents they are just some of the
attacks on Muslims around the country
analysts say that while other groups
have broken lockdown rules
Muslims are being targeted it's a clear
case of Islamophobia Islam is being said
to be responsible for having motivated
these people to go and infect
predominantly Hindu country that is the
kind of narrative which has been soon
after 2,000 people removed from the
headquarters of Tablighi Jamaat the
group that organized the gathering in
Delhi in late March many media outlets
blamed it for the spread of the
coronavirus fifty percent of all the
cases across India and the last one week
are only and only because of the table
key Jamaat markers so who are these
people
television channels and social media
showed fake videos of Muslims breaking
lockdown guidelines and social
distancing norms hashtags such as corona
jihad and corona terrorism began to
trend on Twitter earlier this week
alleged Sleater from the governing
Bharatiya janta party told his
constituents not to buy vegetables from
Muslim vendors Muslim vegetable vendors
are spitting on the vegetables putting
saliva on them and then selling the
vegetables so I told him that we
do much about that but don't buy
vegetables from them
Muhammad Naeem said he abandoned his car
and ran away from his attackers I'll
have to do something to survive but I
can't go back there what's the use
they might beat me again the father of
all is the family's only earning member
the u.s. Commission on International
Religious Freedom has called India a
country of particular concerns since the
Hindu nationalist BJP was reelected last
year
India has rejected the report but the
u.s. body is just the latest to
criticize the government here for its
treatment of Muslims last week the
Organization of Islamic Cooperation
asked India to take urgent action
against what it calls the growing tide
of Islamophobia in the country Elizabeth
puranam al-jazeera New Delhi